this is a production of Cornell
University hello my name is Martha
Williams and I'm studying plant science
in the school of integrative plant
sciences because I love connections ever
since I was a little girl I used to see
how the plants in the soil
became the food that was on my dinner
table and as I've grown older I realized
that plants not only feed the body but
nourish the soul they bridge this gap
that we have between the technological
world we've created and the natural
world from which we have distanced
ourselves they build community for
example I had the opportunity this
summer to work with a handful of
children who work to plan and garden
plant this garden and maintain this
garden I watched how amazed they were
the same that they look at their
technology looking at the plants that
they were growing in the ground and I
saw how and all they were that their
hands are able to create an edible
garden that they were able to tell how
the this these plants had nourished them
and I hope at my time here at Cornell
that I continue to build these
connections because these connections
aren't singular to young people there's
they are shared between people of all
age groups and I hope to not only build
these connections but build community
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu